if i was making 75 000 a year and i was  deciding how much i should allocate  towards my education it would be a  hundred percent of everything beyond my  living expenses it depends on my ages if  i was married if i had kids etc but i  would be living on ramen because i would  want as much of that money to get me out  of making five thousand dollars a year  into making two hundred thousand dollars  or a million dollars a year here's  what's crazy is you can buy the skills  that make you a million dollars a year  for like 50 grand and people just don't  know it you will pay for the information  to make a million dollars no matter what  the question is whether you want to pay  with time or you want to pay with money